was aussieht wie ein kleines
sondereinsatzkommando ist eine coruna
kontrolle in pirna
haben sie kurz irgend jemand der sich
mit uns unterhalten kann zwecks chor
ohne regeln ein anblick an denen man
sich gewöhnen muss zumindest im
landkreis sächsische schweiz
osterzgebirge
wir kommen zur kontrolle der sächsischen
kommunen schutzverordnung würden immer
mit dem hygiene konzept anfang vom
gaststätte haben sie das hier außen vor
ließen
die gäste jetzt dahin auch die kontakt
nachverfolgung das ist alles von
stammgästen okay zum mittag ist ein
drama alles okay gut also dass man muss
alles dann am tisch die leute die
stammgäste kommen gut machen wir das
wenn die bremer kommt dem großen kriegen
da muss ich genauso ein traum die chefin
kommt schnell von zu hause bringt den
aktuellen hygieneplan mit
[Musik]
mitarbeitern des corolla wasser zum
konzept gehört ja die neuen zweig regeln
setzt sie unklar aber innerlich ist sie
hin und hergerissen ich persönlich finde
dass mit dem zweig ziemlich schwierig
umzusetzen weil gerade ich habe viele
gäste die sich regelmäßig an testen
lassen um hierher zu kommen die aber
nicht sich nicht impfen lassen wollen
und die wird höchstwahrscheinlich
wegbrechen wenn ich das so durchführe
und wenn das wirklich jetzigen großen
einfluss auf mein umsatz und auch die
gäste ausmachen wer ist zur not auch zu
machen sind und doch es gab monate lang
auch wird die die ablehnung der chor
ohne regeln regelrecht zur schau
gestellt haben daher weisen wir darauf
hin dass wir keine masken tragen die
tische und stühle so stellen wie wir es
für richtig halten und niemanden fragen
ob er getestet geimpft oder genießen ist
jeder darf also machen was er will damit
muss jetzt schluss sein so der landrat
wir werden also als erstes alles
abarbeiten wo es beschwerden gibt von
wem auch immer
wir werden auch als erstes das arbeiten
wo jemand meint er müsse kundtun dass
man in seiner einrichtung nur rein kommt
wenn man keine maske auf hat oder
ähnliches so was gibt s ja und ich denke
erst mal die werden als erstes von uns
besuch erhalten
internationale touristen machen schon
nach social media ihrem unmut luft es
ist schockierend wie viele restaurants
hier stolz verkünden dass sie die regel
nicht befolgen und anti
wissenschaftlichen quatsch in ihre
fenster hängen
denn irgendwo im freistaat grassiert das
virus schlimmer als hier im landkreis
sächsische schweiz osterzgebirge
die inzidenz ist in kürzester zeit auf
über 1300 geschossen täglich wird es
mehr vertrauen ist gut kontrolle ist
besser das zeigen die behörden jetzt
ganz offensiv bis zu zehn kontrollteams
sind nun täglich unterwegs
landrat seinen kollegen
willkommen um die sächsische corona
schutzverordnung zu kontrollieren bei
ihm
danken
wir sind klein
wegen zwei kunden uns wehren gestellt
wir konnten wir wissen wie viele leute
hier drinnen sind ich kenne die burschen
wissen schon wieder geht
die ordnungsbehörden kontrollieren auch
hier hygiene und kontakt nachverfolgung
kontrollieren sie das zum schluss aber
am anfang zum schluss
gut fünf usern betroffen alles klar wäre
vielleicht besser das am anfang zu
kontrollieren weil wenn jemand nie
geimpft ist oder nicht genesen ist und
dann ist da jetzt hier im st
jetzt wissen wir das ja schon wie was
und wo dem die das schon gedanken noch
die friseurmeisterin ist vor allem über
die präsenz des kontrollteams
erschrocken fühlt sich nicht gut wenn
ihr gleich fünf polizisten gegenüber
stehen
ich weiß ja einerseits dass es notwendig
ist aber andererseits ist es immer eine
unangenehme sache also für mich ist es
unangenehm warum kann ich ihnen sagen
das ist eine reine körperliche sache ich
bin aufgeregt ich fühle mich nicht wohl
dabei
ich mache das natürlich alle die finden
die beamten olibet
doch der landrat macht klar eine andere
möglichkeit als jetzt konsequent
durchzugreifen gibt es nicht
unser gesamtes handeln ist darauf
ausgerichtet ein lockdown wenn es geht
zu vermeiden
wir wollen kein lockdown wir wissen
welche auswirkungen das bei uns auf die
wirtschaft hat insbesondere auf die
vielen vielen kleinen in ihren
geschäften und in ihren kleinstbetrieben
um das zu erreichen will er auch eine 3g
pflicht am arbeitsplatz durchsetzen und
an schulen soll ab sofort täglich
getestet werden und was die kontrollen
der polizeibehörde angeht da gibt es
auch einen klaren plan bei verstößen
wir haben die vorgabe beim ersten mal
ermahnen dann gibt es nach kontrolle und
wenn da immer noch irgendwas nicht
stimmt dann über das geahndet ihre namen
wollen die kontrolleure nicht nennen zu
aufgeheizt sei die stimmung zu viel
aggressivität zu spüren und so trifft
man auch auf missverständnis
manchmal sind die leute in dieser
begeisterung im kontroll und die
behördenmitarbeiter geben sich mühe
immer freundlich und ruhig zu bleiben
weißen die leute ganz sachlich darauf
hin wenn etwas nicht stimmt
während sie in supermärkten weiter die
masken pflicht kontrollieren so die
mitarbeiterin des kaffees gegenüber
misstrauisch rüber wenn in ihrem café
ist seit tagen nicht viel los lohnt
derzeit eine kontrolle gar nicht
jährige an es geht mit 2 geregelt
ein grund für die extrem hohen
infektionszahlen im landkreis ist die
niedrige impfquote gerade mal 51 prozent
sind hier gegen korona geimpft in ganz
sachsen lediglich bisher 58 prozent dass
nun mit 2g ungeimpfte quasi ausgesperrt
werden führt zumindest dazu dass sich
einige doch noch impfen lassen der
ansturm auf die mobilen impft teams ist
seit den einschränkungen enorm
die erstimpfung in wenn man sagen mal
vergleich zwischen oktober und jetzt ist
die zahl gestiegen das ist positiv zu
sehen das sind vor allem eben erst
impfungen sind so um die 19 20 prozent
gestiegen was halt sehr stark angeht
also angeschwollen ist bzw eine hohe
nachfrage hat immer die die
auffrischungsimpfungen die booster
impfungen und tatsächlich die menschen
die diese impfung wollen
die kommen sogar mehrfach zu seinen
impfung und werden auch mehrfach
weggeschickt teilweise weiß nicht reicht
ein anderer denen die immobilien
impfzentren einfach nicht mehr
bewältigen können und weshalb die leute
sauer sind
aber wir waren gestern schon mal hier
müssten aber 14 uhr 30 der impfstoff
ausgegangen dass ich mal wieder nach
hause heute ist immer wieder hier sitzen
jetzt schon eine dreiviertelstunde
und ich denke mal drei stunden wenn man
fast noch hier sein ich sage mal das ist
irgendwie übliche scores für diesen
freistaat da
kreist erzieherin ist man der ganzen
situation ja doch relativ schutzlos
ausgeliefert und weil sozusagen
und da jetzt einfach keinen termin für
eine booster impfung zu bekommen das ist
sehr sehr schade und irgendwie
nicht ganz so nachvollziehbar ärger den
vor allem die mitarbeiter der im teams
abkriegen die seit tagen am limit
arbeiten
diesem sachsenweit durchgängig über der
belastungsgrenze kann man sagen wenn man
quasi hier früh startet man hat schon
bevor man eigentlich wirklich anfängt
schon eine riesige schlange fängt dann
schon aus nummern auszugeben und merkt
schon selber dass man dann schon weiß
okay da sind noch liegt ist noch 50
meter schlange und mehr gegen kathi
zettel aus also die termine aus also ich
werde jetzt gleich irgendwelchen
menschen sagen müssen dass heute nichts
mehr wird und dabei haben wir schon
vorfristig angestanden quasi also bevor
die impfstelle eigentlich auf gemacht
hat dass es belasten dass es belastend
für die teams dafür sind ja auch nicht
ausgebildet sage ich jetzt mal mit mit
auch mit solchen konflikten dann am ende
umzugehen lange und anstrengende tage
auch immer für das gronauer kontrollteam
heute jedoch ohne schwere verstöße
[Musik]
bekommt bzw geben doch nicht immer geht
es so friedlich zu nur kurze zeit
nachdem wir sie einen tag lang begleiten
durfte artete eine kontrolle bei einer
viel zu vollen faschingsveranstaltung
aus die polizisten wurden von den
feiernden mit flaschen beworfen und
getreten immer mehr macht sich eine
aggressive grundstimmung breit in die
die kontrollteams nun aber trotzdem
tagtäglich hinein müssen